who do you listen to
when everyone talking seems to be out of
tune
the government the council the mayor or
your wife
tina over some fish and chips you just
don't know where you are really do you
you know we're trying our best to try to
follow everything they've said
whatever boris says we follow to the
letter don't we
and then all of a sudden you can do this
then you can't do this so i'm very
very confusing bolton now has the second
highest infection rate in the country
so like the rest of greater manchester
they were in local lockdown restrictions
and came out for 12 hours this morning
and now bolton and trafford
are back in nobody knows what they're
doing
there nobody has a clue not not got a
clue whatsoever
you're sending kids back to school but
you can't you have to stay inside and
stuff it's like contradictory i think
government ministers were warned that
lifting restrictions in bolton and
trafford
was premature it appears that what we
had predicted has come to
fruition very unfortunately and now
they've been left with no choice but to
u-turn the issue is that we should never
have got
to this point in the first place and
that when they realized that they
would need to you turn halfway through
the day
on the day when residents think
restrictions are being lifted
is just a ridiculous time to make such
an announcement
but the health secretary for england
stood by the change
in both bolton and in trafford over the
last few days we've seen
quite a sharp increase in cases and the
numbers have have doubled
and so that's why we had to take this
this swift and decisive action today
it's become a reoccurring theme of the
management of local lockdowns in england
late announcements political arguments
and people left
just wondering what they should be doing
in scotland
people in glasgow city western
bartonshire and east
remfucia are now being told not to visit
other people's homes
they've had a month of those kind of
restrictions in greater manchester
some places are making progress but
bolton
has slipped back if the government keeps
it up
if the council do a good job
we have that responsibility we will i
think become responsible
and keep that distancing it's going to
be a very hard thing to do but i still
feel
everybody's responsible and everybody's
got to play their part
some areas have proved that local
restrictions can work
but only if enough people still have the
appetite
to follow them tom parmenter sky news
bolton